fresh clothes from the dryer peaches old
people in love nose freckles homeruns
fingers on the fret board breakfast
tacos cat paws hearing an old favorite
laying in the sand
sunny selfies perfect parking spots kids
playing outside when someone likes you
back wild flowers frozen grapes when
someone likes your post eyelashes old
book smell Slurpees eye contact with
animals new haircuts ice cream
sandwiches picking up with an old friend
someone's smiling at their phone this
emoji sleepy voices first kisses cute
butts thrift store finds winking cancel
plants baby goats catching someone's eye
sparklers otter pops getting text back
immediately
cool sheets happy hour Arnold Palmer's
cooking like an adult when someone
covers you with a blanket dogs who like
you late night pizza actually laughing
out loud
sharing your favorite movie staying for
one more drink a second bowl of cereal
swimming in the ocean baby pictures of
your crush beating that level watermelon
waking up to the rain perfect jeans nail
and karaoke song winning flip cup crying
and wetting indents under your nose
having two episodes to watch finding
something you lost climbing trees
laughing until you cry a house with a
pool a word canoodle watching friends
kill it header on deck chairs when dogs
look at their owners sending LOL
Polaroids snowfall nice emails from
friends empty theatres campfire cook a
cute TBT sunglasses smiling babies live
band horse nasals last karaoke song
doing this in a car hummingbirds disco
naps museums making someone blush
sharing your favorite song dancing in
socks
five bucks in the jukebox I spent three
day weekend playing with your hair able
Sarah tall sunflowers smooth rock a
clean house leonard cohen's voice oh and
one at minigolf conversations that end
like this
[Music]